Scott wolf sportswriter inside USC blog
been covering USC for over 20 years how
did you react to the news that clay
Helton was keeping his job Scott I
probably felt a little sick to be honest
when I heard the news
how surprising was this it was coming
you know for a few days but if you'd had
told me a month ago he was coming back
it would have been surprising I mean
they've got a new president a new
athletic director it looks like they're
gonna make change and it's status quo
and everything's the same now and it's
almost like Lynn Swann is still the
athletic director and you know you don't
see any difference so I thought you know
they were going to clean house but
apparently they're not how much was and
I'm trying to figure this out of who was
available because usually if you make a
coaching change it's because you think
you're gonna get somebody who know
you're gonna get somebody I don't know
if money was a factor and or was the
person they wanted or persons they
wanted not going to be available well
I've heard that they did talk to Bob Stu
and I heard last night that there were
some issues with how much money they
were going to pay his coaching staff if
he were to come and I'm sure they put
out some feelers to Urban Meyer
especially with you know Reggie Bush and
Matt Leinart
sitting next to him every Saturday and
those guys are lobbying him to take the
USC job so you know I don't know how
committed they were to hiring a new
coach I mean it's nice and easy to you
know save millions of dollars on a
buyout but now they're in the situation
where they're going to lose millions of
dollars in ticket revenue and donations
because they've offended the fan base
like I've never seen it in the 20 plus
years I've been covering USC his play
Hilton good
he's good at sucking up to his bosses
the president and the athletic director
because he gave them game balls after
the UCLA game instead of keyed and
slovis school record 500 yards I don't
know how he's good I mean Mike bone was
defending him yesterday but they've been
one of the most 10 alights teams in the
nation the last three years so his job
this year was to clean up penalties so I
don't know how good he can be but also
you had this time frame as you point out
in your column there's like four days
where that elapsed before they said and
we're bringing back clay Helton so
something was happening in those four
days do we know what happened in those
four days they gave really vague answers
about that but my understanding was that
they were talking to Bob Stoops and they
probably were talking to some other
people too and I just don't understand
the timeframe I mean you did they give
themselves three or four days to hire a
new coach they've had you know a long
time to know this was coming so the
deadline seemed kind of weird to me they
should have been talking to someone the
last couple weeks but it just seemed
like they weren't ready to act and and I
don't know why and they're not being
very honest Mike bone said last night
that he didn't even talk to anybody else
and that's definitely not not the case
because otherwise they would have
announced Sunday morning that clay
Helton is coming back it's just still a
coveted job I think so I mean you're the
biggest program in the West and you're
in a pretty bad conference so you're
gonna have the most talent and you can
limit at 12 and be in the conversation
for the college football playoff and
you're not facing most two or three
tough opponents in the big ten or the
SEC so so I think it's a pretty easy job
to have and get to the college football
playoff but they're not even in the
national conversation for that anymore
yeah and they're talented team or at
least you saw you know pockets of talent
on this team if you were gonna make the
hire who would you have hired
I really liked Matt Campbell at Iowa
State I thought he would have been a
good hire for them because he's young
up-and-coming and they would probably
had to pay him as much of some of these
marquee guys but you know I don't even
know if they talked to him and it didn't
seem like they did so it just wasn't a
good search now if they've gotten Urban
Meyer that would have been great you
know everyone would have been happy and
I think Bob Stoops everyone would have
been happy but honestly any coach would
have been better I think in my eyes of a
fan so it would have been easy I I
always say you just hire a mannequin
because the mannequin won't do any
damage and clay Helton does do damn it
just a head coach so I think anybody
would have been better Scott thank you
for your time thank you for your
opinions I appreciate that
thanks Dan that Scott wolf he's a sports
writer for inside USC and it's been
covering USC for 20 years for more Dan
Patrick show tune in to audience Channel
239 on DirecTV stream for free on BR
live or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]